hi
my name is markiplier and welcome back
to hoonipop i am about to go on a date
with two lovely ladies yes take me
please
uh on the date i mean
okay i also forgot to assign date items
but are we boys this is just what i
needed
my shoulders have been tight for days
now
are we all gonna fit on that table you
aren't really wearing clothes
that's just you're wearing a scarf all
right anyway hey
what's up guys hey how you doing um
i have gifts that are gonna spoil
uh can you take this
then what do i do with this
what do i do with the shrimp what do i
do with it why does no one want my
shrimp
all right you know what hey what is up
guys
ah back at it again with another
sick move i'm looking up a bit of a
sweat here
yeah you should it's uh hot in this room
it's really
hot hey abia abby
oh god if they exhaust i die will not
die
but you know it's not gonna be happy
that is it yeah it's there it was red
blood but that yeah that is what that
was yeah that was definitely blood
what was the question god just let me
get one of these big combos god
god let me get a goddamn combo keep
going
i will nothing can stop me
this won't do anything for you but it
will do something for you
oh you absorb them
oh you sh that's kind of dastardly
i would really like to make some actual
moves
i would really enjoy that i would really
like it
i would love it if i could
but it's just sentiment i don't have
anything for the sentiment to do
i'm almost out of moves oh my god i
didn't even realize
oh my god i'm almost out of moves
because these
lovely ladies wouldn't let me get my
combos on
don't exhaust don't you exhaust
you take this
is that good enough for you well it's a
good thing you're gonna
steal this oh gimme gimme yeah
gimme gimme yeah you just you do that
oh [ __ ] god damn it i meant for that to
be
there oh my god it's fine
[Music]
i'm gonna make it definitely this is
this will exhaust her ah she doesn't
have enough damn
well you also like music and you got
more passion so
that didn't do nearly as much as i
thought it was going to well
god damn it again with this crap it
wouldn't let me get the comments and
ah
give me your fruit give me a free give
me the fruit fruit me
fruit up the storm became the fruit god
damn it you make me look
bad i don't understand this feeling how
am i
turned off oh my god
you all of you just shh shut up
i'm leaving i'm leaving i was living
no one wanted my shrimp
[Music]
it's such a peaceful day isn't it now
i'm here
anything could disturb this trench oh no
[Music]
excuse me hello yeah sorry i think i got
it wrong
but i'm practicing i promise wait
i've seen you around recently you're the
new assistant to mrs bell rose right
this is bell rings i'm sookie
well that's my japanese name anyway
it's a pleasure to meet you sookie i'm
leilani
i work at the hotel occasionally the
massage spot too
ah really i work with a real japanese
girl
oh no i'm not
you're tan too it's just like me o
m g do you also like dyaru fashion
no uh
[Music]
well i'd love to but i don't
i mean i'm not ah
i can't believe i'm actually best
friends with a tan
japanese girl
uh what's that smell
you smell that it smells like like a
[ __ ] weeb ugh i have to put up with
enough of this [ __ ] back home
anime is popular down here you should
see sky
garden where do you think the designs
for these love fairy uniforms came from
rescue hotel girl before this dweeb
makes her watch an entire season of some
magical chan girl [ __ ] okay cool yeah
anyway
uh i i i i am here
i once had sex with the japanese girl
i had sex with one you
did want to have sex with a japanese
girl where'd you find her well
wait you went to japan didn't you
what was your favorite part uh well uh
the rich heritage
i've never been to japan before but if
they have that then the rich
and hentai heritage sure yeah
i'm so so so so jealous
but but but i might be going there soon
mrs bell rose says she'll take me there
if i behave myself and do a real good
job
okay you got it that's all well you
better do a good
job then huh yup yup i'm trying
don't always do whatever she tells me to
lie when i visit japan
you'll show me all the best spots right
right
uh suki i don't live in japan
it's gonna be super duper fun
[Music]
is there you know my sixth sense is
usually pretty good about this and i am
not picking up on that anybody want it's
gone
the shrimp has turned to dust thanos
snapped my
shrimp away but you know i could talk to
you
you know what i've been thinking about a
lot lately me have you ever had a lucid
dream
where you're aware that you're dreaming
yes i don't think i'd want to be
aware of that it sounds creepy well i
mean most of my lucid dreams are
kind of nightmares so uh kind of creepy
think so
yeah you can see why you would say that
yeah you can see that
hey hey i have a question okay do you
like chubby girls
[Music]
sure a little chub
okay good because um i tried to lose
weight a couple times
but it's way too hard i get that i
understand it
much like identifying the heritage of
people you're looking at
embarrassing i love the embarrassment
you know how to use
um a vibrator
a friend bought one for me but
i've never used anything like that
before
i think
[Laughter]
crazy
[Laughter]
are you sure yeah yeah it's painful
trust for
me i i i'm just talking about it makes
me embarrassed
i i know i don't think sex toys are for
me
you know that's fine sheepish won't
allow any hygiene or sex toy they'd get
hygiene
kind of dirty [ __ ] what what
when she's exhausted or upset because
it's too embarrassing okay cool
sure
great oh wait now i remember even better
do you have any cavities
no is that really true are you trying to
trick me
uh why would i lie about that okay so
what i've learned
is i'm gonna give you guys
food and that's just gonna be the end of
it you want a burrito
then what do you do with it then what do
you do with it
what you you wanna
what do you do
[Music]
i know the resort prices can be a little
excessive no i paid for it with fruit
that erupted out of your
very own cleavage would you like a
burrito you don't have enough stamina to
eat a burrito
how intensely do you eat burritos
whatever hey i'm all
ears
i've been addicted to yoga lately the
resort has its own studio
i haven't missed a class yet
we have the same interest friendship
level up
[Music]
oh my god i suppose it couldn't hurt to
take a break and do something fun
exactly and i know fun i'm 100 fun you
remember our last date on the cruise
that was fun huh were we at a cruise
someone was at a cruise with me and they
had fun i know this i hope i don't get
too wet
i still have to go to work later
i'm about to destroy
this
can you please stop that i didn't what
did i do
what
[Music]
damn it ah one too low oh god no
oh god no ah
[ __ ] oh
give me a passion where i need it god
damn it damn it
cool if i fail another date i'm gonna
i'm gonna lose my mind
oh [ __ ] but wait
wait but wait wait no
wait ah god damn it
god damn it oh my god there's no way out
freak freak
[Music]
that was super duper not fun
let's go see what lola's up to let's go
say hi to lola hey
um excuse me hi miss i'm sorry what's
your name yes
i'm who me hi
nora can i help you with something hi
hello to my room earlier this morning
right
uh maybe i don't know i cleaned a lot of
rooms this morning
okay well some jewelry went missing from
my room this morning
you wouldn't happen to know anything
about that would you
nope sorry oh all right
it's just i could have sworn it was on
the nightstand before you came in
i don't know what to tell you but i
didn't take your [ __ ] if that's what
you're suggesting
who else could have taken it you were
the only person in the room aside from
me
look i'm sorry if she went missing but i
don't appreciate being accused of [ __ ]
i didn't do oh yeah
she definitely took it yep that's one of
the advantages of having fairy vision
i can see people with transparent
clothing whenever i want
it's clearly in her left pocket we're
not here to solve crimes though
we are here to sleep with two chicks at
the same time
so you gotta de-escalate the situation
and get these two to
like each other okay sounds good hey
they call me the matchmaker
they call me the negotiator they call me
[Music]
maybe it fell in the trash hmm i
seriously doubt it but i'll go double
check just in case
jesus what the [ __ ] is her problem
uh maybe she likes you and just wanted
to get your attention
hey what kind of dumb ass [ __ ]
explanation is that
hey wait a second from a dumbass the guy
in room 216.
yeah what the [ __ ] did you spill on your
sheets this morning
i brush in bed it's the only way to get
the cavities away
nah i'm pretty sure that ain't
toothpaste i wasn't exactly minty fresh
i ain't mad i'm just trying to figure
out how the [ __ ] you managed to do it
now i have no idea what you're doing
everywhere and still couldn't find it
that's okay it happens will you at least
let me know if you happen to come across
it
yeah for sure if it turns off somewhere
i'll let you know
i detect something here kind of like a
bonnie and clyde situation
kind of like uh what the criminal on the
pla well there's a story here somewhere
tortoise in there i don't know what i've
always wondered about you
everything what accomplishment in your
life are you most proud of
well you know this illustrious youtube
career you know
i've made quite a few projects you know
impacted a lot of people's lives i'm a
hero you know
not all heroes wear capes i once had sex
with an
alien breath like a nail series yeah
yeah i don't know what got into me that
day
i guess it had been a while
okay okay be honest with me will ya
okay how close are you with your family
oh
i well uh family very important
no doubt family's all we got you know
[ __ ] i don't know where i'd be i know i
know
hey let's just get some extra stamina
take this yeah yeah yeah you know
what better i love being just better
than doing nothing that's my priority
i ain't stupid enough to put my money in
these things i'll just watch you guys
lola lola
lola looks different i didn't do
presents again
dagnabbit okay whatever
why does this music remind me of like
the snes aladdin game for some reason
no one's ever gonna get that but i don't
know why but i feel it
oh my god oh my god
let me do a chump change one just to
beef up the numbers
oh my god
i know good god look at me
all right we gotta get there's no stamin
tokens on the board there's three and
they're so far away from each other
how am i supposed to be able to do that
oh my god um give me something
please
why
oh there oh okay now we got it okay
we're good
[Music]
come on give me something this would be
where items would really come in handy
but i don't have them because i didn't
plan
why don't i plan because i get
distracted by boobs
oh my god this is so absurd
what the hell give me anything
excellent they're finally something
something
okay i think i'm gonna make it i think
i'm definitely gonna make it all right
uh it's in the bag it's in the bag
the bag oh it's okay i'm gonna win it
everybody else yeah well watch this
still a success pretty nice yeah
nice fruit nice nice good fruit great
fruit actually incredible fruit
love the fruit love the fruit now i
remember why i like you so much
thank you most people do remember
eventually
they come back around it's like a year
like a four year cycle ah i guess i sort
of like got a confession to make
i uh i did take your jewelry
i'm sorry okay i know it's [ __ ] up i
just cash is tight you know
my cousin she don't really make enough
to support her kid and like
she ain't got nobody else to help her
hmm
you know what keep it what
no no it ain't right here you gotta take
it back please
really it's fine i've got plenty of
jewelry
it seems like you need it more than i do
you know yo
i don't know what to say this is pretty
cool don't worry about it
i think there might be another way you
can pay me back this is pretty wholesome
i would love to pay this see this is a
nice
wholesome dynamic everyone else not
quite
so wholesome or dynamicized
but you know it is what it is let's go
say hi to the cousins
at the gift shop funny enough i'm
finally gonna learn this goddamn gift
system youtube again tonight huh
yeah i guess i'll have to make do
i'm gonna make do all night long for you
[ __ ]
i can't believe i haven't asked you this
yet what do you think there's anything
so serious that we shouldn't joke about
it
uh you know i remember
when wade broke up our friend jesse
started making breakup jokes pretty much
the same night so
i think everything should be on the
table people are way too uptight these
days
yeah it's like [ __ ] relax it's a joke
uh what do you think about it how stupid
your answer will be to this
okay wow followers do you have on clicky
pick
uh well i just broke seven figures
last week well sorry i broke seven
figures
five years ago you literally expect me
to believe that
whatever you have shut up
as far as you have none douche
on my gifts doing you guys want gifts oh
you have the fox plush i forgot that you
actually do
have that can i take that away from you
i don't really want to but if i could
i would can i organize these uh let's
get the sense down here didn't i get
like a pine scent yeah right there
let's get the shoes on this level
plushies on this slime your cute animal
uh flowers and sex toys here definitely
and jewelry as well perfect
got it nailed it you want pero um
yeah i'm gonna have to go with
no fine okay
goth girl okay
these are literally the sickest shoes i
think i've
ever seen yeah i know
um
that's pretty cool
and that'll do okay cinnamon got it
let's go on a date i
was gonna lay around and do nothing but
you can do that with me i can wait yeah
of course it can wait
i can't wait for our date which is going
to be great
oh the royal suite quite the date
damn why couldn't my boss put me up in a
place like this
uh well do you hear the romance in the
air
i'm willing to bet that you do there's a
lot of it in the air
it's floating around how does air
work nobody knows
you and me we're gonna make some
memories tonight
many many memories that we'll remember
for a long time because that's how
memory works
i don't know if you knew that how did
this happen
there's something going on there okay
not bad
i know i know
the old gift technique huh don't have to
baby me
i don't think that giving you cinnamon
was babying you
i'm pretty sure that's not what that was
almost
seven moves i can still screw it up or i
can go
for the glory and i choose glory every
time
oh baby
yes done
hey it would be great if you both could
start yes
erupting fruit seeds
please thank you
all right time to take a hike lil my
friend and i have some
grown-up stuff to do oh really i'm not
a kid and i'm not leaving i want to [ __ ]
him
too so how about you lean i
would oh this round
now wait hang on i wasn't ready for it
hang on wait i i gotta see
wait no hang on i'm oh my god i use this
poor performance i'm aware
but uh the problem is please censor
everything don't don't
stop the noises the noises don't
actually need to be
anything now of the thing that's
happening so please ah
where's a match i don't know matching
is hard here we go whoa
it's like a roller coaster
jesus christ
you're not getting tell my parents about
that are you
are you kidding me lil nobody can
ever find out about this [ __ ] right
no one i might have recorded this
through my eyes
definitely depositing that in the spank
bank you were
also recording that got our first pair
of fairy wings
whoa who got we'll need a lot more than
that to awaken the nymphogen though
why so keep doing what you're doing man
make mama sugar dust proud i
might just do that anyway
ladies i'll see you around i gotta go
catch on the flippity flip hey rolling
stones
it's me i feel so lucky to be able to
wake up in this
beautiful pair you should worry sing
this but i can't help myself what's up
what are you thinking about right now
well you know math
is weird have you ever wondered like why
one is one and two is two
there's like infinity in between every
numbers there's a lot of numbers in
between one and two but
one is one and two is two like if you go
one point one one one one one
you can keep going on the once until
infinity technically that is infinity by
itself but also there's one one one one
one one one one two
two two two and that is also an infinite
series of numbers so infinity is really
weird huh but mathematic is just a
representation of what's happening in
reality
but when you think about it even further
the division between one atom and
another there's an infinite amount of
space in between them
but it's such a small amount anyway in
comparison to the larger amount
so really like does anything actually
have value
anyway boobs are great yeah
round one soft ones perky one
squishy ones
[Music]
yeah that too hello i may have
underestimated the cost of vacationing
things really add up quick yeah i'm
gonna have to try to move twice as much
inventory next month to make up for it
inventory what inventory i
i'd be happy to have don't even think
about it i appreciate the offer but i
don't need anyone's help
that's fair this woman makes her own
money and pays for her own things thank
you very much
that's good i like that i like that
[ __ ] off jesus christ okay
no date gifts unless 30 well that made
it a little difficult
but that's okay you got three date gift
slots
woman in charge
fine for
[Applause]
it's foreign cute thank you you're
welcome is it customary to offer shoes
to girls in your country
yes always very common i do it all the
time
yeah smoothie wait what what flavor is
that
it's amazing yeah it is it is isn't it
it is it isn't it
it's fashionable hey what a coincidence
i just recently lost my other one yeah
oh i could have that to the anks dt now
damn it
oh that's nice oh yeah okay and then
blue
it's kind of nice got blue theming
purple theming kind of works
i get that that's nice hey nachos
nachos you want nachos yeah good nachos
for me thanks
nachos still getting used to not having
to cook for my brothers
nachos nachos date date now
on vacation it'd be a shame not to right
it would be a shame you know what else
is a shame at me
how about we get a massage have we been
here before we hope we don't have any
embarrassing accidents again what
accident is that gonna be
all right get no i can't but i can
that is it this bottom row is like
locked up tight i can't
get anything down there
[Music]
no you do so much for me already oh yeah
you
oh yeah okay you gotta get all right
the whole baggage thing god damn it
okay
that's helping that's helping a little
bit not much
didn't help didn't help actually no help
no help not helping
not helping no help good good help yes
help
oh thanks you're welcome now you do this
such a wonderful gift i know
[Music]
yes you are
beautiful uh it's a lot closer than i
was hoping it would be
good god uh [ __ ]
uh you yes excellent
oh i did it never mind it's not closed
at all hey look at us
look at our scenes wow we
really did it guys we did it we did it
we did it you did it
how about we take it all the way home
[Music]
wow
here we go i'm ready oh uh wait
uh hang on gotta plan the perfect move
here
hold on i'm gonna get i'll get a red one
here eventually don't you worry
red is uh coming in i have actually i'll
get that yeah that's good
i'm screaming too it's so exciting yeah
wow yeah right oh my god
this is the censored version right good
god
was a very throughout investigation
throughout what did you say just
doing my job lola what did you say
back up lixie and i know you were
averting your eyes but i need you to
replay what
lola just said did she say thoral
now that was a very throughout
investigation
my god i didn't think i could love her
anymore
all right i'm going back because i got
some outfits oh
i can't believe you get to smack all
these titties around and i just have to
watch
what a chip lola where's the outfits
where's the outfits oh wardrobe fun
pick out some [ __ ] stuff so we have
some eye candy to enjoy
well i mean i'm thinking more dignified
you know dignified popping off
elegance the cream puff which doesn't
make
a lot of sense but i like it i like it a
lot
no i like the i like the original i
think that's good
[Music]
tiffany
you know what maybe i think the hair is
just a bit much so we're gonna go we're
gonna go
the outfit yeah we're good there
[Applause]
hey thank you everybody so much for
watching what a fun experience what a
wholesome game it's good stuff if you
agree
let me know down in the comments hey if
you think this is wholesome
fun that anyone can enjoy and doesn't
deserve to be age restricted
hit the like button maybe that'll
convince
susan wojcicki to believe that this
video should be monetized
i think that's the direct line of
communication i'd like to think that
inner office is a buzzer
and every time someone hits a like
button it buzzes a very loud obnoxious
tone
and that's just how she relaxes so
like for that thank you and as always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
you